der 21 September 2022 ein Schock für
viele junge Russen
Putin verkündet die talmobil-machung
hunderttausende junge Männer rekrutiert
für den blutigen Angriffskrieg in der
Ukraine
davor sind sie geflüchtet Nicolai
goriatschew aus Moskau und da sehen die
schipkopf aus Jekaterinburg sie haben es
bis nach Berlin geschafft weit weg vom
Zugriff der russischen Armee
[Musik]
das war total unerwartet und ein Schock
für mich ich bin ja sehr jung und könnte
einberufen werden deshalb haben meine
Eltern mich praktisch gleich am nächsten
Tag nach der Verkündung der
teilmobil-machung weggeschickt diesen
Tag und diese Nacht werde ich nicht
vergessen ich habe überhaupt nicht
geschlafen eilig meinen Koffer gepackt
und musste in Begleitung meines Vaters
nach Kasachstan flüchten
nur Tage nach seiner Flucht erhalten
arsenischipkows Eltern Post der
Einberufungsbescheid
auch Nikolai goriatschef fühlte sich
nicht mehr sicher hatte Angst vor der
Einberufung als Kriegsgegner habe er
bereits unter Beobachtung des russischen
Geheimdienstes gestanden
die Chance das auch ich einberufen werde
schätze ich als sehr hoch ein denn viele
politische Aktivisten haben einen
berufungsbescheide bekommen
er als Soldat für seine Kriegsmaschine
einsetzen kann daran besteht kein
Zweifel
[Musik]
in Russland gelten alle Männer ab 18
Jahren als Reservisten und bekommen
diesen roten militärpass weil sie beide
schon vor der Teilmobilmachung ein
Touristenvisum für die EU hatten konnten
sie nach Deutschland einreisen hier
haben sie politisches Asyl beantragt
doch ihre Chancen stehen schlecht weiß
Rudi Friedrich der mit seinem Verein
viele kriegsverweigerer berät
die deutsche Bundesregierung hat im Mai
zugesagt dass dieser Türe aus der
russischen Armee ein Flüchtlingsschutz
bekommen sollen und die große Frage ist
aber für all diejenigen die klug genug
waren sich rechtzeitig den Rekrutierung
zu entziehen und die ist überhaupt nach
Deutschland geschafft haben was
schwierig genug ist
für die gibt es keine Regelung keinen
Schutz das Bundesamt für Migration und
Flüchtlinge hat Asylanträge von
russischen kriegsverweigerern abgelehnt
eine der Begründungen lautet es sei
Zitat nicht mit beachtlicher
Wahrscheinlichkeit davon auszugehen dass
der Antragsteller der nicht über
militärische Vorkenntnisse und auch
sonst nicht über Spezialkenntnisse
verfügt überhaupt gegen seinen Willen
zwangsweise zu den Streitkräften
eingezogen wurde
da wird mit Argumenten abgelehnt
Argumente die gar nicht mehr Stimmen in
Russland gab es verstärkt Rekrutierungen
und die haben auch so stattgefunden dass
ganze Häuserblöcke abgesperrt worden
sind und kontrolliert wurde
wenn das in U-Bahn im Bussen und
dergleichen rekrutiert wurde und alle
Männer die in dem Alter waren wurden
einfach mitgenommen
das bestätigen auch Berichte des
unabhängigen russischen
Nachrichtenmagazins Medusa auf dem
telegram-kanal aus der orangen
hannoverski haben Augenzeugen Videos von
Rekrutierungen an der Moskauer Metro
gepostet
Polizisten halten junge Männer an
kontrollieren ihre Papiere augenzeugen
berichten von Männern die in weißen
Busen abtransportiert werden
in St Petersburg arbeitet die Anwältin
Elena Popova das Militär sei bei der
Rekrutierung oft willkürlich und
gesetzeswidrig vorgegangen
das
schwierigste ungefährlichste war die
gewaltsame Einberufung die während der
ersten mobilmachungswelle massenhaft
erfolgte
Opfer waren oft Arbeiter die in die
Großstädte zum Geld verdienen gekommen
waren und in Hostels übernachteten die
Polizei kam dann nachts oder am frühen
Morgen und hat allen gesagt sie müssen
dringend los man hat ihn ihre Pässe
weggenommen dass alles verstößt gegen
das Gesetz
viele einberufene sein außerdem mit Geld
und falschen Versprechen gelockt worden
vielen von ihnen wurde im Wehrkreis
Kommando versprochen dass sie nicht an
Kampfhandlungen teilnehmen werden ich
spreche viel mit Ehefrauen von Männern
die schon dort sind und die Nase voll
haben vom Krieg sie wissen nicht wie sie
da rauskommen ich frage warum ist dir
Mann dorthin gegangen er dachte er macht
jetzt schnell gutes Geld und zahlt dann
seine Schulden zurück aber in
Wirklichkeit ist alles ganz anders und
er will das überhaupt nicht mehr
denn es gibt Berichte dass gerade
unerfahrene Reservisten an vorderster
Front verheizt werden und in Massen
sterben
Schätzungen des norwegischen
Verteidigungsministeriums gehen von
insgesamt 180.000 gefallenen und
verwundeten russischen Soldaten aus
putin ist auf weiteren Nachschub
angewiesen sagen Experten
es ist nicht ausgeschlossen das ist eine
noch malige offizielle große
mobilisierungswelle gibt aber ich glaube
eher dass man versucht unter diesem
Dekret dass er weitergeht die Zahl
deutlich zu erhöhen denn wir sehen im
Moment auf allen Ebenen den Versuch
Russlands sich auf einen längeren Krieg
vorzubereiten also das Militärbudget
wird deutlich erhöht die Gesamtzahl der
Soldaten soll in den nächsten Jahren auf
1,5 Millionen erhöht werden und das
zeigt dass es wirklich darum geht
erstmal nur Masse zu generieren und die
hohen Verluste auszugleichen die
Bundesregierung hatte erklärt allen
Russen die nicht am Angriffskrieg
teilnehmen wollen Asyl zu gewähren
Bundeskanzler scholz sagte noch im
September Zitat ich bin dafür diesen
Menschen Schutz anzubieten
und Justizminister Buschmann twitterte
noch am Tag der Teilmobilmachung
anscheinend verlassen viele Russen ihre
Heimat wer putinsweg hasst und die
liberale Demokratie liebt ist uns in
Deutschland herzlich willkommen
trotzdem lehnt das Bundesamt für
Migration und Flüchtlinge kurz BAMF
Asylanträge von kriegsverweigerern ab in
der SPD-Bundestagsfraktion löst das
Unverständnis aus
sie bekommen Asyl wenn sie sich dem
Dienst sozusagen entziehen also
desertieren wenn sie schon bei der
Truppe waren aber es ist natürlich
eigentlich absurd eine solche
Unterteilung vorzunehmen weil das ist ja
am Ende besser wenn sie überhaupt gar
nicht im Militär gelandet sind und
deswegen muss es eine schnelle Lösung
geben und ich gehe auch davon aus dass
es jetzt eine sehr zeitnah Lösung gibt
Nachfrage bei SPD Innenministerin nennt
sie Feser ihre Behörde sieht
Handlungsbedarf Asyl könnte es in
Zukunft auch für Russen geben die vor
der Einberufung geflohen sind Zitat
für diese Personengruppe wird die
Entscheidungspraxis des BAMF aktuell
überprüft sie wird in Abhängigkeit von
dem Ergebnis der Prüfung gegebenenfalls
angepasst
für Aktivist Friedrich kann es nur eine
Lösung geben Asyl für russische
Kriegsdienst Verweigerer das sind Leute
die sich dem Krieg entziehen wollen und
würde man sie abschieben würde man
praktisch den Kriegsherren des
Menschenmaterial dafür liefern
Nikolai goriatschef und arsenisch wollen
sich hier ein neues Leben aufbauen
Nikolai möchte wieder in seinem Beruf
als Fitnesstrainer arbeiten und da seni
möchte sein russisches Abitur nutzen um
hier ein Studium als Dolmetscher zu
beginnen eine Rückkehr nach Russland für
beide momentan ausgeschlossen
egal wie sich mein Leben wendet ich kann
mir nicht vorstellen nach Russland
zurückzukehren man kann in den Krieg als
Kanonenfutter geschickt werden ich werde
das nicht tun niemals
ich kann nicht zurück die Risiken sind
zu groß meine Ansichten erlauben es mir
nicht in Russland zu leben und ich will
Putins Regime unterstützen
sollte ihr Asylantrag abgelehnt werden
können Sie zunächst nicht nach Russland
abgeschoben werden da ist derzeit keine
Direktflüge gibt doch sie würden weiter
in Ungewissheit leben eines Tages
vielleicht doch in den Krieg ziehen zu
müssen